a police officer and now a
self-confessed sex killer
wayne cousins faces the grimmest time in
prison
he snatched sarah everard off the street
raped her
and strangled her he still hasn't
explained why
wayne cousins lied to the police when he
was arrested
and to date has refused to comment
we still do not know what drove him to
commit this appalling crime
against a stranger for a week colleagues
of pc cousins searched for sarah
on her route home around clapham common
in south london
the marketing executive had been
visiting a friend and decided to walk
the two miles to her brixton flat
her family and friends joined police in
appeals for the public's help
officers found sarah's body 50 miles
away
in remote woodland in kent it was hidden
in a builder's bag
by then police were on to pc cousins
a metropolitan officer for only three
years
his job armed protection of parliament
and embassies
he'd been acting oddly he was driving
along the road at the time
sarah vanished he was in a higher car
detectives seized his own car at his
home in deal
and wondered why he'd needed to hire
another
analysis of his mobile phone showed he'd
been in the woods where sarah was found
and he'd been buying tape and the sort
of rubble bag in which he'd been hidden
it wasn't much evidence but it was
enough for him to admit his guilt
all of us in the met are second
angered and devastated by this man's
crimes
they are dreadful
and everyone in policing feels betrayed
the investigation is under scrutiny a
dozen officers met
and other forces may face misconduct
charges
one issue the arrest of cousins on
indecent exposure allegations
days before he killed miss everard
cousins appeared by
video link from prison he sat hunched
his hands clasped together
staring at the floor rocking slightly
from side to side
his lawyer jim sturman qc said he would
have to bear the burden of his crime
for the rest of his life and he told his
lawyer
i will deserve it cousins will be back
in court in two months
the sentence will be life imprisonment
the number of years
will be many martin brunt sky news at
the old bailey